[Music]
prayer is nearly upon us and even at
this early point I can safely say you
need this game Arkane Studios creators
of the dishonored franchise who also
assisted on level design for Bioshock 2
are back with prey which is a narrative
driven first-person shooter we've seen
the opening hour of the game and if you
don't want any minor spoilers please
look away now
here are 10 things you should know about
pray imagine if Bioshock dishonored
half-life deus ex and dead space had an
illegitimate child that offspring would
be prey the intergalactic horror of dead
space the look and feel of dishonored
and deus ex the first-person alien drama
of half-life and the progression system
seen in Bioshock it's all here does it
work as a single entity only time will
tell
there was another pre game back in 2006
and although a sequel was planned it
never met fruition Arkane Studios
swooped in but does that continue the
story set up eleven years ago to be
blunt
no no it doesn't raphaël colantonio the
president of arcane says in his cool
French accent prayer is not a sequel
it's not a remake it has no ties to the
original so it's safe to say you don't
have to go back and play the original
prayer this is a reimagining you play as
Morgan you who wakes up bright and early
to start his first day of a new job he
has a helicopter convoy and wears a
snazzy spacesuit so he must be important
right oh and when I say hey I could mean
she as you'd expect with a genderless
name like Morgan you can choose to be
bro Morgan with a swept fringe and three
days of stubble off then Morgan with a
lazy ponytail and far less facial hair
it turns out that the story isn't set
1,000 years in the future like many
games who have a similar sort of
storyline but only 15 years away
frighteningly close the story does
change our past however with JFK
surviving his assassination in 1963
which means the guy with three names who
shot him could
still be out here now what was that guy
called Camilla Camilla parker-bowles
Billy Ray Cyrus I remember it's Haley
Joel Osment anyway all of this history
changing has resulted in more funding
going to the space program creating
amongst other things a space research
facility known as Talos 1 this is where
things go off the rails within your
first 30 minutes you realize you are not
on earth but in fact you're on Talos 1
does that mean you work at an
intergalactic space research facility or
are you the one receiving the research
so to speak smashing a window for the
first time to see reality is quite
impactful so don't watch that bit you
just watched sorry
after the tension has been built up for
about 10 minutes you finally meet the
mimics which are the baseline enemy in
this game but they do live up to their
names
if that happened a little bit too fast
let's have another look again the mimics
aerospace parasite that can mimic
objects in their surroundings so this
little blighter hid in plain sight as a
coffee mug think about what this means
when you play through isn't that bin a
bin or is it a mimic is that chair
really a chair this simple enemy will
scare the hell out of you over and over
again and this is just one of many
enemies wait till you meet these buggers
you'll notice many dead humans with
haggard looks on their faces and when
you do remember this scary fact
[Applause]
[Music]
aash one human plus one mimic equals one
dead human and four mimics it's gonna be
a tough ride so how do you fight these
little monstrosity x' well with weapons
of course starting with a trusty wrench
like the crowbar you had back in
half-life you can squish mimics you face
but bigger enemies require bigger guns
shotguns work a treat but look at the
glue cannon this is like a militarized
expanding form weapon which sticks to
and freezes enemies where they stand
allowing you to show them who's boss the
glue cannon also can create makeshift
bridges walkways making it invaluable if
you played Bioshock you'll be happy to
know that plasmids are here okay they're
not exactly the same but in terms of
upgrades prey borrows a great deal from
the Bioshock trilogy neuro mods are
praised way of ascending Morgan's
abilities in three core areas scientist
engineer security engineering is based
around modding and repairing your
weaponry security is more about what
your character can physically do and
scientists is for health upgrades and
using specialized lab equipment so when
can we get our hands on prey not long at
all it is scheduled for release the day
after Starr was there May the fifth what
do you think of prey not bothered never
seen it before or you can't wait to play
it or maybe you're looking forward with
healthy skepticism please let me know
below a like will be hugely appreciated
and maybe think about subscribing to our
little Channel I imagine from
PlayStation grenade I'll see you next
time
[Music]